we're all about to go try the tastiest
pizzas in l.a and let me tell you right
now my pick's gonna win no mine's
clearly the tastiest you guys know me i
know the best pizza in l.a
let's settle this on the pizza floor
[Music]
i think my feelings on pizza are best
summed up pizza is like sex in that even
bad pizza is still
pretty good the tastiest pizza in los
angeles is at disano pizzeria in
hollywood what they do there is make
just this classic neapolitan style pizza
in giant
brick wood fired ovens
piping hot crust charred just right
perfectly melted cheese crispy juicy
meat and that first bite
is just it's heaven hello my name is
giovanni mejia i'm an executive chef
here at the sano pizzeria in los angeles
california and today i'm going to show
you how to make our pizza i'm going to
go ahead and grab one of these dough
balls make sure i cut exactly where i
need to cut it goes in the flour goes in
the flour i got gotta make the corichony
which is a crust spread the air that's
already built up into the dough ball
okay i want to make sure i spread that
to the edges of the dough i'm gonna
stretch this out by hand so you've done
this a couple times though i've done
this uh more than a few times in my
lifetime yes sir go ahead and put this
onto our marble table here we're gonna
do the cheese first here why do you do
that the style of this pizza is very
thin in the middle if i was to go ahead
and put the sauce beforehand it's gonna
get soggy i'm gonna throw some caramels
on there flowing in from italy yeah
everything's getting flown in from it
yes sir our tomato sauce is made with a
san marzano tomatoes and that's like the
best right that's what everybody wants
so we're going to go ahead and put some
of this our already cheesed pizza here
no this is caramelized onion caramel is
done yes it gives it a nice sweetness to
it these here very special pepper juice
imported from south africa sweet yet
mild now we hand pull these uh tennis
sausage okay into a desired size and
last you might we're gonna throw some uh
mozzarella de beaufoll on it's super
creamy super rich and super delicious
all right i'm gonna go ahead and put
this in here yeah
just like that how hot is it in that
oven 800 degrees 800 degrees in there
the ceiling is over 1000 degrees wow i
just want to point that out it's two
different temperatures it's been maybe
15-20 seconds but this pizza is almost
done i just give it a quick turn half
turn okay so you can make sure it's an
even cook and i'm going to dome it so
you bring it up yeah i bring i char it a
little bit gives it the nice oh look at
that yeah nice caramelization a little
blacken the peppers a little bit that's
great this is it mike
oh yeah that tomato sauce is
so good so fresh they're not overloaded
with sauce too because i feel like
that's a common pizza problem it allows
the ingredients to really shine through
for sure and the crust just has the
perfect amount of chew those peppers are
really good they're interesting it's not
like crazy it won't like chase you out
of the room huh
so much flavor sausage is one of my
favorite toppings on pizza sausage
yeah if it's a good sausage and you get
that
nice like oil who's
those people who blot their pizza with
paper towels that's blasphemy
that was delicious but i'm sticking with
my pick the tastiest pizza in la hands
down is that doughbox my family's from
chicago we've grown up eating deep dish
pizza and i miss it taking a bite from a
piece of pizza at doughbox is like a
journey the dough is crispy and crunchy
the cheese is thick and gooey the sauce
is the perfect balancer between the two
i know people say less is more but in
this case more is more my name is tony
hernandez my name is alexandra gonzalez
we're going to show you how to make a
pizza so we're making a large chicago
deep dish pizza this is our dough made
fresh every night we do put butter
that's sort of what makes it a little
softer and tender than most
place it in here almost like a biscuit
dough you just form it into the pie one
thing i like about our pizza is it's not
that thick definitely about the toppings
here so we use a whole milk mozzarella
from wisconsin we line the bottom and
cheese it's sort of like an upside down
pizza so that's about how much cheese we
would put in it so we get a nice helping
of the ricotta
cheese so this is italian sausage
italian sausage yeah made by a local guy
right down the street
so what about this tomato sauce the
sweetness is natural everything is
natural we don't add anything love that
it's just tomatoes which i think makes
it for you let them shine so now the the
pie goes in the oven so this is going to
take between 25 to 35 minutes to bake it
bakes in two stages once uh the first
stage is over i took it out of the pan
and put it as it is naked as the second
stage yeah yeah final touch with a brush
with olive oil we sprinkle with a little
pecorino romano and then we have uh the
greek oregano and then we put it in the
box
okay we're opening it
oh
damn this ain't pizza honey this is deep
dish oh yes it's thick just like me do i
get a napkin or i'm just going ham on
this thing that's what you do in chicago
oh my god look at that layer
nathan get get it closed
okay so
[Music]
oh i'm not saying that's honey
phenomenal i'm gonna lick my hand
the dough is so flaky like it's not like
a regular pizza crust the crust is like
so buttery chop what does that mean i
don't know an italian guy makes it down
the road that's so cute like i love like
a regular pizza sauce that i'm like used
to like neapolitan style yeah but this
is like straight off the bottom yeah
it's like taking a bite of like a big
delicious tomato i see you alex
this your little secret weapon all right
doe box y'all set the bar really high
but we're going to my spot now the
tastiest pizza i have ever had is at
costa buona in los angeles california
and it's the pepperoni pizza the thing i
love most about pizza is very like
simple ingredients
pepperoni
cheese
sauce
bread chef zach makes this most amazing
simple pepperoni pizza because he really
took a lot of effort in sourcing
the best ingredients all around the
world and all of that energy and soul
and heart that has gone into perfecting
that recipe you can't help but love it
because it's delicious i'm zach [ __ ]
and i'm the chef and owner of costa
buona here in echo park and we're gonna
make my favorite pepperoni pizza in the
world today we have our dough here we
want to flour it so that it doesn't
stick together as we pull it out and
then separate at the seams pull it out
and now this is there's a bit of
technique here for sure we want to make
it as round as possible because that's
the shape of our pizza and we're going
to push to the air
that's in it out to the edges so we want
to develop the cornichon is what they
call it in naples but basically the
crust we want a nice aerated puffy crust
this is the part i always mess up at
home this part yeah or the next part
it's probably this part this part oh
that part too what the hell did you just
do
like the the slapping technique wow we
have a perfect little sparkle how did he
do that all right so now we have our
tomatoes the glorious bianco tomatoes
and put down a little bit of the low
moisture mozzarella this is a imported
provolone picante it's like a spicy
provolone and then this is our pepperoni
which
comes from i can't tell you because it's
top secret it's great now but it's even
better when it's cooked and it fills
those little cups with the brony fat and
what doesn't fill in the cups is renders
on the pizza it's glorious put a little
bit of parmigiano-reggiano
and now we bake so we drag it ever so
gently toss it in the oven this will
cook in about
50 seconds 60 seconds depending on how
hot the oven is but it's around a
thousand degrees i'm gonna finish it
with a little wild sicilian oregano and
raw uncooked parm and now we'll cut her
up
chef zach
what you got i have a pepperoni pizza
for you guys
with a side of ranch
[Applause]
i never expected a gourmet chef to hand
me a side of ranch and a pepperoni pizza
there we go the crust is beautiful look
at that char look at the pepperoni the
little pepperoni cups kind of capture
the wrench
damn that ranch is real good this ain't
no hidden valley ranch though those
little crispy pepperonis the way they
curl up i feel like you're getting extra
crispy
surface area apparently it's a secret
they won't tell us where they're from
they're secret for a reason oh no
it's perfectly fluffy and crispy at the
same time too
light
you're very quiet no yeah cause i'm
eating this this pizza my favorite pizza
has not changed i am sticking with the
big gun doe box la hands down i'm sorry
zack but my favorite pizza has changed
and the reigning
champion is
you i win i'm a man of principle i stand
by my original choice even though i
changed my mind last episode
sure did listen doe box fantastic also
it's a pizza casserole it's deep dish
it's not even close to the same thing
that's fair but i mean pizza so i want
some of that pizza right now yeah i mean
i would eat i know oh you would eat
another one it's great
[Music]